bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat sauf surprise c'est
donc ce matin que les sénateurs
devraient rejeter le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale et
les sénateurs communistes ont confirmé
hier lors d'une conférence de presse
leur intention de voter contre la partie
recettes de ce texte
eliane assassi présidente du groupe
communiste a expliqué yves hier que le
gouvernement est bien n'avait pas
entendu la démarche des sénateurs
communistes en retoquant la plupart de
leurs amendements l'ump va également
voté contre le budget de la sécurité
sociale
jean claude gaudin a estimé et bien que
ce plfss étaient animés par la seule
ligne directrice du matraquage fiscal
même son cloche du côté de lui des us et
françois zocchetto a dénoncé et bien
l'attitude du gouvernement son manque
d'ouverture très peu réceptifs selon lui
aux propositions des centristes pour
améliorer les recettes de la protection
sociale à leurs conséquences de ce
nouveau coup dur pour le gouvernement
bien tous les amendements qui ont été
adoptés par les sénateurs
jusque là sont de fait rendu caduque
il y aura une cmp commission mixte
paritaire réunissant à la fois des
députés et des sénateurs
elle aussi elle semble bien vouée à
l'échec et comme vous le savez c'est la
constitution qui le prévoit s'il ya un
désaccord c'est donc l'assemblée
nationale qui aura le dernier mot tout
de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
bonne matinée tous l'ordre du jour
appelle la suite de la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'assemblée
nationale de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2013
dans la discussion des articles nous
sommes parvenus à l'amendement numéro 76
tendant inséré un article additionnel
avant l'article 33 avant l'article 33
articles 235 terre edge et du code
général des impôts et je suis saisi donc
d'un amendement cet amendement
effectivement numéro 76 de monsieur
watrin c'est madame pascale
merci monsieur le président cet
amendement et sa collègue n'est pas
nouveau puisque nous l'avons déjà
défendu déposés et défendu lors de
précédentes lois de financement de la
sécurité sociale
il s'agit avec cet amendement
d'instaurer une contribution fiscale
exceptionnelle à la charge des cliniques
commerciales portant sur leurs bénéfices
et dans le bénéficierait au sein de
santé qui représentent des difficultés
financières importantes
initialement notre taxe portée sur le
chiffre d'affaires et monsieur cahuzac
nous avait alors répondu que notre notre
amendement n'était pas recevable dans la
mesure où certaines d'entre elles
étaient en grande difficulté nous
voulons naturellement pas leur porter
atteinte
ou plus précisément ne pas porter
atteinte aux emplois de leurs salariés
nous avons modifié notre amendement pour
que la taxe ne porte plus sur le chiffre
d'affaires mais sur les bénéfices
réalisés par les sociétés qui possèdent
ces cliniques
pour mémoire les bénéfices du 1er groupe
français sont passés de 24 à 59 4
millions d'euros grâce à quoi elle a
versé d'énormes dividendes à ses
actionnaires
et là encore nous posons avec cet
amendement la question de l'utilité et
la réorientation de l'argent si ma chère
collègue avis de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur général
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
chaque collecte amendement propose de
créer pour 2012 une taxe exceptionnelle
sur le bénéfice des cliniques privées
égal à 2%
cette recette serait affecté au centre
de santé dans la perspective d'une
redéfinition du service public
hospitalier et d'une loi d'accès aux
soins que maintenant le ministre a
annoncé il ne me semble pas judicieux de
poser ainsi les cliniques et les centres
de santé
chacun a sa place dans notre
organisation il faut trouver les
meilleures modalités de fonctionnement
et de financement
d'ailleurs la convention qui lie une cam
et les centres de santé va être
renégociés dans les prochains mois ce
qui permettra de mieux prendre en compte
leurs spécificités et de conforter leur
place qui est indispensable en ce qui
concerne clinique
il est vrai que nous avons assisté ces
dernières années au rachat
d'établissements par des groupes
financiers
je crois manama min
5e devront réfléchir à cette question
pour tenter de revenir un système plus
traditionnelle de propriétaires mensah
présentant moins d'inconvénients
en termes d'accès aux soins sur ces
éléments la commission des affaires
sociales a souhaité le retrait de
l'amendement
si l'amendement est maintenue la vie
donc sera défavorable
si monsieur l'important génère l'avis du
gouvernement madame la ministre
oui monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs un avis
défavorable madame la sénatrice à votre
amendement les établissements de santé à
but lucratif ce qu'on appelle les
cliniques lorsqu'elles font des
bénéfices payent des impôts au titre de
l'impôt sur les sociétés et donc apporte
une contribution est par ailleurs
lorsque leur chiffre d'affaires est
supérieur à 250 millions d'euros
une contribution exceptionnelle sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés de 5% et de
plus exigé il nous semble par ailleurs
que établir un lien qui pourrait être
perçu comme une opposition entre centres
de santé et cliniques privées n'est pas
souhaitable indépendamment de la
question de savoir comment on pourrait
déterminer une taxe affectée
je rappelle qu'une mission est engagée
pour préciser le modèle économique des
centres de santé auquel le gouvernement
est très attaché nous devons faire en
sorte que soient mieux reconnus mieux
financer certaines missions spécifiques
des centres de santé et c'est dans la
perspective de cette mission que nous
nous situons pour garantir le
financement des centres de santé sans
vouloir encore une fois opposé les
établissements entrent donc avis
défavorable à votre amendement merci est
ce qu'il y a des explications de vote
l'amendement est maintenue madame
fasquets je vais donc mettre aux voix
cet amendement qui a reçu l'avis
défavorable et de la commission et du
gouvernement
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il n'est pas
adoptée à l'article 33 je suis saisi
d'un amendement
210 rectifié du groupe ump madame
procast ya qu'il défend non c'est même
de roche
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mme sheikh collègues
l'article 33 présent le prévoit la mise
en place d'une gestion commune par la
ccmsa de la trésorerie des organismes de
mutualité sociale agricole y compris
celle du gamme ex est organisé en
conséquence le transfert de la propriété
des réserves du gamme nex à la ccmsa le
gamin qui est une association regroupant
17 entreprises d'assurances qui a été
créée par la loi de 1961 pour gérer le
régime obligatoire de l'assurance
maladie des exploitants agricoles
service des prestations et recouvrement
des cotisations
aujourd'hui l'existence du gamme ex aux
côtés de la ccmsa garantit aux assurés
de liberté de choix pour la gestion de
leur protection sociale en santé ainsi
qu'une qualité de service reconnue
services en ligne accor de
télétransmission accueil téléphonique
or au détour d'une disposition visant à
pérenniser les moyens de fonctionnement
de la msa celle-ci en fait organisé
l'absorption de gamme nex par la ccmsa
en prévoyant un transfert de sa
trésorerie et surtout un transfert de la
propriété de ses réserves
en effet en privant le gamme ex de ses
fonds propres et de sa trésorerie
c'est le fonctionnement la gouvernance
et la pérennité même de celui ci qui
sont remis en cause
de telles modifications et donc pour
conséquence de réduire à néant la
liberté accordée aux exploitants
agricoles de choisir l'organisme
gestionnaire de leur protection sociale
en santé
c'est pourquoi il est proposé par cet
amendement que le gamin ex conservent la
pleine gestion de sa trésorerie et la
pleine propriété de ses réserves dans
l'intérêt de ses assurés merci madame
ruth de roche à vis de la commission
monsieur rapporteur général
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
chers collègues cet amendement on entend
supprimer les deux dispositions de
l'article 33 relative dispositions
relatives aux gammes ex le gamme ex est
un groupement d'entreprises d'assurances
créé en 1961 pour gérer le régime
obligatoire d'assurance maladie
des exploitants agricoles donc service
des prestations et recouvrement des
cotisations
actuellement 6 % des assurés sont
affiliés à cet organisme
l'article 33 qui réforme le système de
financement la gestion administrative de
la msa prévoit la centralisation de
trésorerie et des réserves des caisses
locales au niveau de la caisse centrale
de la mutualité sociale agricole à des
fins de cohérence le gamme ex est
également concernée par ce que je
pouvais donc cette remontée de la
trésorerie
en effet la trésorerie constitué par le
gamme ex ne lui appartient pas il s'agit
de la trésorerie de la gestion des
prestations du risque maladie
il n'y a donc aucune légitimité a laissé
ses trésoreries haut gamme ex au
détriment du régime obligatoire
d'assurance maladie des exploitants
agricoles l'avis de la commission des
affaires sociales est donc un avis
défavorable à cet amendement
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre mais ma vie des savoirs à
monsieur le président pour les mêmes
raisons excellemment présentée par
monsieur le rapporteur général
merci jeu est ce qu'il ya des
explications de vote
je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement 210 rectifié qui a reçu
l'avis défavorable et de la commission
et du gouvernement quels sont ceux qui
sont pour son adoption
avis contraire il n'est pas adopté nous
en arrivons l'amendement 398 présenté
par le gouvernement madame la ministre
oui monsieur le président il s'agit
d'une mesure concernant les artisans
ruraux qui n'emploient pas plus de deux
salariés et qui sont affiliés au régime
social des indépendants pour tous les
risques sauf en ce qui concerne la
famille
il paie donc ces artisans leurs
cotisations personnelles pour ce qui est
de la famille et la csg crds à la
mutualité sociale agricole et non pas au
régime social des indépendants comme
pour les autres cotisations sociales
cette situation apparaît peu lisible et
source de complexité pour les artisans
qui doivent donc payer leurs cotisations
personnelles auprès de deux organismes
selon des règles et des calendriers qui
sont différents cette double affiliation
apparaît
complexe à la part elle provoque en
outre des difficultés de gestion qui
peuvent conduire à ce que ces artisans
se voit réclamer les cotisations
d'allocations familiales ainsi que la
csg la crds par les deux organismes
collecteurs c'est à dire à la fois par
le rsi et la mutualité sociale agricole
le présent amendement vise donc à
remédier à cette situation en procédant
à la filiation des artisans ruraux
n'employant pas plus de deux salariés de
façon permanente au rsi pour l'ensemble
des risques
cette solution est conforme aux règles
qui concerne les autres artisans ruraux
c'est à dire ceux qui emploient plus de
deux salariés et la proposition qui vous
est faite est soutenue par les
représentants de cette profession merci
madame la ministre à vis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues donc la
commission n'a pas pu examiner
c'est un moment donc j'interviens à
titre personnel pour souligner qu'il
s'agit bien d'une mesure de bon sens qui
devrait mettre fin aux difficultés de
gestion qu'engendre la double
affiliation des artisans euros
n'employant pas plus de deux salariés
dont les conditions que je viens
d'indiquer l'avis est favorable
merci monsieur l'important génère est ce
qu'il ya des explications de vote
il n'y en a pas je vais donc mettre
voilà mandement 398 du gouvernement qui
a reçu l'avis favorable du rapporteur
général
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire il est adopté je
vais donc mettre aux voix l'article 33
est ce qu'il ya des demandes de prise de
parole il n'y en a pas donc quels sont
ceux qui sont pour adopter l'article 33
avis contraire il est adopté
après l'article 33 je suis saisi d'un
amendement 77 qui le défend c'est mal à
masquer oui merci monsieur le président
ce sera très rapide
comme vous le savez nous considérons que
les professionnels de santé qui ne
respectent pas les règles en matière de
respect des tarifs opposables doivent
eux faire l'objet de sanctions
en l'état actuel du droit à l'article l
162 1 14 1 du code de la sécurité
sociale prévoit que les médecins qui
pratiquent des dépassements d'honoraires
et qui ont été sanctionnés pour ceux là
peuvent faire un cas de récidive l'objet
d'une sanction particulière prenant la
forme de la fiche est de la sanction
devant le cabinet du professionnel cette
sanction baptisé name and shame chez les
anglo saxons et que l'on peut traduire
en france par crainte de la honte nous
apparaît être une mesure efficace pour
éviter les récidives
tel est le sens de cet amendement merci
ma chère collègue avis de la commission
sur un porteur général monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues dont quelques explications
l'article l100 62 à 14 1 du code de la
santé publique prévoit depuis la loi
hpst que la cpam peut prendre
l'expression peut prendre des sanctions
à l'encontre des professionnels de santé
en cas de discrimination de dépassements
d'honoraires excédant le tact et la
mesure où non conforme à la convention
et d'omissions d'information sur les
tarifs pratiqués le présente amendement
qui a été rédigé pour l'examen de cette
loi entend remplacer l'expression
peuvent faire l'objet de sanctions par
donc font l'objet de sanctions
il apparaît à mes yeux que cette
nouvelle rédaction n'apporte pas
réellement de valeur ajoutée juridique
concrètement il ne peut pas y avoir de
sanctions automatiques pour ce type
d'infraction n'ont en revanche le récent
avenant numéro 8 et la convention
médicale a supprimé la référence à la
notion de tact et muet de mesures pour
la remplacer par une série de critères
plus pertinents à mes yeux est plus
opérationnel il a aussi organisé une
nouvelle procédure de sanction qui me
semble plus efficace que celle de
l'article du code de la santé publique
les deux étant d'ailleurs exclusives
l'une de l'autre au vu de ces éléments
la commission des affaires sociales a
souhaité le retrait de l'amendement si
l'amendement est maintenu
la vie donnée sera un avis défavorable à
son adoption
merci à vis du gouvernement madame la
ministre oui un avis défavorable dans la
mesure où non seulement la l'amendement
ne paraît pas constitué une avancée
significative par rapport à la loi mais
surtout pour la raison que le dispositif
qui était prévu dans la loi hpst qui n'a
pas trouvé d'ailleurs de dispositions
d'application puisque le décret
d'application n'est pas sorti et le
dispositif qui était prévu s'inscrivait
dans la logique de la politique menée
par le précédent gouvernement qui
consistait à concentrer l'action de
maîtrise des dépassements d'honoraires
sur certaines professions et de façon
d'ailleurs tout à fait insuffisante
puisque en réalité il s'agissait de
permettre que ces dépassements
d'honoraires soit prise en charge par
des organismes complémentaires et pas du
tout de limiter les dépacements eux
mêmes ça n'a pas été la proche de ce
gouvernement lorsqu'il a souhaité que
s'engagent des discussions entre les la
caisse de falla la cnams les organismes
complémentaires et évidemment les
syndicats de médecins libéraux
discussions qui ont abouti à un accord
accord qui doit s'appliquer dans
quelques semaines et qui permettra à la
fois de lutter contre les dépassements
abusifs en permettant que ces
dépassements soient sanctionnés de
limiter les déplacements non abusif dans
le cadre d'un accord favorable aux
patients puisque les patients seront
mieux remboursés qui permettra à près de
10 millions de nos concitoyens d'avoir
la garantie de bénéficier des tarifs de
la sécurité sociale
donc il nous semble que il me semble que
l'accord qui a été signé permet de
répondre à vos préoccupations en tout
cas ça n'est pas du tout dans le cadre
de la loi hpst que nous nous situons
j'ajoute pour terminer que votre
amendement me semble constituer un
cavalier sociale dans le cadre de
l'examen de ce projet de loi je dois
dire que je suis assez étonné qu'ils
apparaissent
en partie recettes puisque en tout état
de cause cela n'aura aucune incidence
sur l' équilibre des comptes de la
sécurité sociale dans la mesure où les
dépassements d'honoraires ne relève pas
neuneu ne sont pas prises en charge par
la sécurité sociale
merci madame la ministre l'amendement
est maintenue madame mosquée je vais
donc le mettre aux voix avec avis
défavorable il est retiré pardonnez moi
alors nous en arrivons toujours après
l'article 33 un amendement 282 qui le
défend c'est madame archimbaud vous avez
la parole
monsieur le président cet amendement est
retiré nous espérons évidemment que le
dossier n'est pas clos mais il est
nécessaire de réfléchir et plus
largement au delà de la question des
dépassements d'honoraires à la
rémunération des médecins
merci donc l'amendement est retirée nous
en arrivons à l'article 34 avec une
prise de parole de monsieur dominique
watrin vous avez la parole
oui je voudrais profiter de cet article
34 qui permet à la cause de fournir au
régime des mines d avance exceptionnelle
de trésorerie à hauteur de 250 millions
d'euros
si j'ai bien compris celles ci sont
censées venir compenser la diminution
des crédits de la caisse des dépôts et
des consignations qui n'excède seront
pas en 2012 qui n'excède pas en 2012 et
650 millions d'euros
cet apport est donc le bienvenu même si
je dois vous dire mon inquiétude quant
au devenir du régime minier et des
centres de santé qui lui sont attachés
ces derniers intégrés aux régimes de
sécurité sociale minière permettent une
approche globale des besoins en santé en
protection sociale des assurés relevant
du régime minier la fermeture de ces
structures aura un effet mécanique sur
cette offre de soins souvent ouverte à
toute la population et ne manquera pas
d'aggraver le drame social dans des
territoires qui souffre déjà plus que
d'autres de la précarité du chômage de
la pauvreté et surtout des retards de
santé comme vous le savez les centres de
santé du régime min
pratique la gratuité totale des soins là
où ils sont ouverts à toute la
population il constitue d'ailleurs le
meilleur atout de ces territoires pour
combattre les retards de soins et
réduire les inégalités de santé
cet héritage particulier repose sur deux
fondements tout d'abord les mineurs ont
cotisé durant toute leur vie un taux
supérieur à celui du régime général
qui plus est la dangerosité le caractère
pathogène de l'activité professionnelle
des mineurs justifier la pratique de
cette gratuité totale
j'ai pris acte madame la ministre de
l'instauration dès votre arrivée d'un
moratoire sur le devenir du régime
minier des 180 centres de santé qui sont
rattachés moratoire rendu nécessaire
après que le précédent gouvernement a
imposé sans concertation ni dialogue
le fameux décret d'août 2011 en fixant
qui fixait à 2013 la date de disparition
du régime minier nous souhaiterions donc
savoir où en est cette concertation
si vous envisagiez à ce jour de
prolonger la durée du régime minier
garantir à ses assurés sociaux
le rétablissement de leur droit
dérogatoire au droit commun c'est-à-dire
plus pro des protecteurs je pense
particulièrement au rétablissement plein
effective du dispositif appelé
communément 2 2 b qui consiste en des
remboursements de frais de transport
curé pharmacie en faveur des affiliés du
régime minier
car malgré les annonces faites par votre
prédécesseur les assurés nous affirme ne
pas avoir encore vu réellement ses
droits spécifiques rétabli cela a des
conséquences directes sur la santé des
assurés principalement qui sont
principalement des retraités en perte
d'autonomie dont la prise en charge des
transports et des cures est aujourd'hui
entravé faut-il rappeler qu'il ne s'agit
pas ici de demandes de confort mais bien
de nécessité justifiée pour pour des
ayants droit
usé par les conditions de travail
parfois d'habitat des conditions
particulières dont l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé est réduite par rapport à la
moyenne de la population
merci mon cher collègue amendement
numéro 9 de la commission sur le
rapporteur général
monsieur le président madame lise chaque
collègue il s'agit simplement d'un
amendement de cohérence à d'actionnaires
merci à vis du gouvernement
merci je vais donc mettre aux voix
l'amendement numéro 9
quels sont ceux qui sont pour son
adoption avis contraire je n'en vois pas
il est adopté je vais mettre aux voix
l'article 34 quels sont ceux qui sont
pour l'adoption de l'article 34 avis
contraire il est adopté à l'unanimité
article 35 qui souhaitent prendre la
parole
je vais donc le maître voit quels sont
ceux qui sont pour l'adoption d'articles
35 avis contraire il est adopté
article 35 bis je suis saisie de deux
demandes de parole tout d'abord celle de
monsieur jean pierre godefroy
oui monsieur le président madame la
ministre dire pas de prise de parole
comme prévu puisque l'amendement déposé
par le gouvernement
amendement 395 rectifié donne
entièrement satisfaction il répond aux
préoccupations qui étaient les nôtres et
donc en conséquence nous retirons nous
notre amendement 259 rectifié bis merci
madame cohen oui c'est une prise de
parole plus de demandes de en fait de
précisions il a pour objet de simplifier
les modalités de versement des
cotisations dues sur les indemnités de
congés payés dans les professions pour
lesquels existent des caisses de congés
payés et ils prévoient donc que les
cotisations sociales patronales et
salariales du sur les indemnités de
congés payés serait donc si cet article
était adoptée acquittée dans les mêmes
conditions que celles appréciable pour
l'ensemble des cotisations sociales
or cette disposition aurait pour effet
de renverser la logique actuellement
définis aux articles l 242-1 et r200
43-6 du code de la sécurité sociale qui
prévoit que le versement des
rémunérations c'est à dire d'en cas
précis les neg les congés payés
constitue le fait générateur de
cotisations malgré la présentation qui
en était fait en sciences pub
qu'à l'assemblée nationale nous avons
l'impression finalement en tout cas nous
percevons mal la finalité de cet article
qui appliqueraient au secteur du btp des
mécanismes dérogatoire est ce que ce
nouveau mécanisme qui correspond en
quelque sorte un paiement anticipé des
cotisations ne peut pas générer une
forme de complexification pour les
gestionnaires mais également avoir des
conséquences financières notamment dans
le cadre donc des congés prises par les
salariés du secteur
donc voilà est-ce qu'on peut avoir
quelques éclaircissements sur cette
question et pour tout savoir comment
nous allons nous positionner
je vous remercie merci ma chère collègue
nous avons en discussion commune deux
amendements puisque 259 rectifié a été
retiré l'amendement 244 de jean paul
amoudry qu'il défend monsieur van den
berg
oui monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues pour les
mêmes raisons qui viennent d'être
exprimée par jean pierre godefroy nous
retirons cet amendement puisqu'ils il
est satisfait aux dires des caisses de
congés payés concernés par l'amendement
du gouvernement
merci amendement numéro 2 165 rectifié
terre du monsieur gilles merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre je ferai
comme mes collègues précédent si nos
amendements déposés sont satisfaits par
l'amendement gouvernemental je suis mon
aussi tout près à le retirer mais comme
l'ont fait mes collègues avant moi je
souhaiterais avoir bien sûr quelques
éclaircissements sur cet article et sur
l'amendement du gouvernement merci merci
on chers collègues nous en arrivons à
l'amendement de 395 rectifié du
gouvernement madame la ministre
oui merci monsieur le président à la
suite d'un de certains rapports il est
apparu nécessaire de simplifier la
gestion des cotisations et donc
l'article du projet de loi initial qu'il
a pu être débattu à l'assemblée
nationale avait précisément pour
objectif de simplifier
la situation de ne pas n'avait pas la
volonté d'ajouter un coup de trésorerie
pour les entreprises et en même temps de
donner toutes les garanties de
transparence sur la manière dont ont été
gérés ces cotisations il est apparu que
certaines interrogations existent et il
nous a paru nécessaire de sécuriser la
réforme proposée dans le temps pour ne
pas provoquer de difficulté et donc à la
suite de concertation avec les caisses
nous présentons cet amendement qui a
pour objectif de restreinte dans un
premier temps le prélèvement à la source
au versement transport et à la
contribution au final ce qui ne pose pas
de difficultés aux entreprises
concernées et dans le même temps nous
mettrons en place un groupe de travail
avec les représentants du btp qui
remettra ses conclusions avant le
printemps prochain à l'âme
mois de mai 2013 et à ce moment là nous
verrons comment avancer avec les
entreprises dans la démarche que nous
avions envisagé à la fois de
transparence et de sécurisation
il me semble donc que l'amendement qui
est présenté à porte réponses à vos
préoccupations à celle des entreprises
du secteur et donc je vous remercie
d'avoir bien voulu retirer vos
amendements au profit de celui du
gouvernement
merci maintenant la milice avis de la
commission sur la porter général merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cet amendement du
gouvernement on devrait au doigt même
permettre de répondre aux craintes
soulevées notamment dans les fédérations
des bâtiments et travaux publics par
l'article 35 bis en effet l'amendement
supprime les dispositions de l'article
35 bis qui prévoyait que les caisses de
congés payés n'interviendrait plus dans
le versement aux urssaf des cotisations
patronales et salariales du sur les
indemnités de congés payés
à la place il propose qu'un rapport soit
remis au parlement plus tard le 1er
juillet 2013 sur la question
l'amendement prévoit également que le
versement transport et le versements
destinés au fonds national d aide au
logement soit directement versés aux
urssaf par les entreprises la commission
des affaires sociales donc les miens
avis favorable à cet amendement
merci monsieur le rapporteur général est
ce qu'il ya des explications de vote
monsieur gilles merci monsieur le
président ne peuvent pas spécialement
une explication nos ventes mais pour
confirmer ce que je disais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que devant les
éclaircissements donnés par madame la
mini je retirais bien sûr mon amendement
merci je vais donc mettre voile
amendement du gouvernement qui a reçu
l'avis favorable de la commission quels
sont ceux qui sont pour son adoption
avis contraire je n'en vois pas il est
adopté je vais mettre aux voix l'article
35 bis
quels sont ceux qui sont pour adopter
cet article 35 bis avis contraire il est
adopté
nous en arrivons donc à l'article 35 ter
il n'ya pas d'amendement quels sont ceux
qui sont pour l'adoption de l'article 35
ter avis contraire il est adopté même
vote pour l'article 36 même vote
il est adopté abstention pardon
l'abstention du groupe ump
je vais mettre voit donc la troisième
partie du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2013 je
rappelle que lorsque le sénat n'adopte
pas les dispositions de cette partie la
quatrième partie de ce projet de loi est
considéré comme rejetée monsieur le
rapporteur général vous souhaitez
prendre la parole vous l'avez merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues dans quelques
instants nous allons procéder au vote de
la troisième partie du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
conformément à ce que prescrit la loi
organique
je voudrais d'abord remercier l'ensemble
des intervenants qui ont pris part à
l'examen des articles relatifs aux
recettes nous débats ont été me
semble-t-il riches souvent passionnées
peut-être quelquefois excessif mais
aussi très souvent fructueux je voudrais
simplement à cet instant vous inviter à
vous interroger sur le sens de notre
vote au cours de la discussion
la majorité sénatoriale a su se montrer
rassembler sur des articles ou des
amendements essentiels
c'est ainsi que nous avons rétabli
l'article 14 sur la rémunération des
gestionnaires de capital risque
nous avons pris des initiatives pour
introduire une nouvelle taxe
nutritionnelle sur l'huile de palme je
pense avoir fait preuve d'un esprit de
conciliation et de responsabilité sur
les droits de consommation sur les
bières à beaucoup de moments et sur de
très nombreux amendements
nous avons vu aussi se constituer dans
l'hémicycle ce que j'appellerais des
majorités à géométrie variable
c'est ainsi que l'opposition sénatoriale
a pu faire voter
obligatoirement et arithmétiquement avec
l'apport de voix de groupe de la
majorité sénatoriale des dispositions
alors quelques fois majeur quelquefois
mineurs je rappellerai quelques-unes
incitation à l'usagé du vélo exonération
de la prévoyance de taxe sur les
salaires suppression du passage au réel
pour l'emploi à domicile
fléchage de la totalité de la casa au
département c'est la loi de la
démocratie parlementaire et ne souffre
aucun commentaire
quelle doit être notre vote maintenant
on peut prendre ce vote comme consistant
à approuver la politique fiscale du
gouvernement
la commission des affaires sociales
considère que le plfss
et son volet recettes et pleinement
respectueux des engagements de la
majorité sénatoriale et notamment de ses
votes intervenus l'an dernier mais on
fait le constat et je le vois bien que
beaucoup ici trouvent à redire sur tel
ou tel point sur tel ou tel article
faut-il donc transformé le vote sur la
troisième partie alors que nous n'avons
pas encore examiné tous les articles
qu'il nous reste près de 200 amendements
en une sorte de motions préalables
intervenant en pleine discussion je
pense et je le dis fortement à ceux
également que ce serait profondément
dommage je pense que nos concitoyens ne
le comprendrais pas c'est tout le sénat
qui se trouverait fragilisée et pas
seulement sa majorité il ne s'agit pas
de continuer à discuter simplement pour
le plaisir de discuter
cependant la maladie la famille la
vieillesse les accidents du travail
le secteur du médico médico social ne
méritent ils pas un examen sérieux et
approfondi de tous les groupes
politiques et dans leur diversité
n'avons nous pas et sur tous les bancs
des propositions à formuler
n'y at il pas là des enjeux qui sont
majeurs pour notre pays
c'est dans cet esprit que je vous invite
à ne pas repousser cette troisième
partie avant de prendre nos responsables
étaient chacun dans nos groupes
politiques ayons le courage de regarder
le texte de manière globale d'éviter un
vote tronqué les sons l'examen d'un
texte fondamental se poursuivre je pense
que ce serait bien pour le sénat ce
serait bien pour notre protection
sociale et ce serait bien aussi pour les
français je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général la
parole est à madame assassi monsieur le
président madame la ministre nous voici
donc au terme de deux jours des débats
sur qui et nous sommes donc amenés à
nous prononcer sur la troisième partie
de ce projet de loi de finances de la
sécurité sociale relative aux recettes
je crois que nous l'avons dit à
l'occasion de nos différentes
interventions
il ne peut y avoir de renforcement de
notre sécurité sociale qu'à la condition
de renforcer durablement son financement
et enlace ayant sur des dispositions qui
soit juste qu'ils soient solidaires qui
soit conforme aux principes fondateurs
du conseil national de la résistance
alors c'est vrai le sénat a adopté des
mesures positives en matière de
financement je crois que nous avons
aussi contribué à les faire adopter
je pense par exemple à l'article 11 qui
rompt avec la fragilisation économique
du régime social des indépendants et à
l'élargissement de l'assiette de la c3s
toutefois nous regrettons que le
gouvernement ait fait le choix de
préférer un financement à 6 sur les
mesures d'ordre fiscal plutôt que de
faire le choix du renforcement des
cotisations sociales
alors c'est vrai le rehaussement du
forfait social générera des ressources
dont la sécurité sociale a
particulièrement besoin
or ces ressources aurait été plus
important encore si vous aviez opté pour
l'intéressement et la participation par
exemple un assujettissement à
cotisations sociales
alors cette mesure aurait eu
un double avantage créer des droits pour
les salariés notamment en matière de
retraites et inciter les employeurs à
privilégier les salaires qui sont fixes
annuels et collectif au détriment de
formes de rémunérations qui sont
individuelles et dépendent du bon
vouloir des employeurs alors au delà de
son aspect je dirais technique le débat
entre finances forme par la cotisation
et financement par des taxes nous paraît
essentiel c'est le débat du modèle
social que nous voulons construire pour
les agniers les années à venir
alors si nous sommes attachés aux
cotisations sociales c'est que nous
considérons qu'il s'agit d'une forme
socialiser de salaire que c'est une
forme de salaire différé ponctionnés sur
la valeur ajoutée créée par le travail
les cotisations sociales sont en fait un
prélèvement d'utilité sociale sur des
sommes qui si elle n'était pas orientée
vers la sécurité sociale irait à la
rétribution des dividendes et à la
spéculation
d'ailleurs pendant que certains
dénoncent à droite le coût du travail
c'est à dire qu'il souhaite que les
employeurs ne participe plus au
financement de la sécurité sociale
nous avons voulu porter quant à nous le
poids du capital sur la sécurité sociale
nous avons présenté notre amendement de
modulation des taux de cotisations
sociales en fonction de la politique
salariale des entreprises ainsi que
celui instaurant une contribution sur
les dividendes détenus par les
entreprises
le débat en la matière a été je crois de
qualité il faudra le poursuivre il nous
semblerait toutefois que la majorité de
gauche du sénat et le gouvernement
pouvait parvenir à dégager des recettes
nouvelles pour la sécurité sociale en
reprenant les dispositions adoptées par
le sénat à gauche lors de l'examen du
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2012
alors certes malgré la sagesse du
gouvernement nous avons pris acte du
vote par la majorité de gauche de
l'autre amendement sur la taxation des
parachutes dorés
dès lors qu'ils excèdent de cinq fois le
plafond de la sécurité sociale
mais d'autres recettes d'ailleurs elle
aussi adoptée ici par la majorité de
gauche au sénat l'an dernier serait tout
autant aujourd'hui nécessaire tout
simplement parce qu'elles sont justes et
c'est particulièrement vrai s'agissant
de l'instauration d'une contribution
patronale sur la part variable de
rémunération des opérateurs des marchés
financiers à hauteur de 20% et la
suppression des exonérations de
cotisations sociales patronales aux
entreprises ne respectant pas leurs
obligations en matière d'égalité
salariale
ces mesures auraient pu se substituer à
l'article 16 instaurant la taxe sur les
retraites comme vous madame la ministre
nous souhaitons une réforme de la
dépendance
or nous souhaitons qu'elle puisse
d'abord et avant tout partir des besoins
de nos concitoyens et qu'à partir de ses
besoins on établisse le niveau de
financement nécessaire celui ci ne peut
reposer sur les futurs bénéficiaires au
motif qu'ils auraient cotiser pour
pouvoir bénéficier d'un droit nouveau
l'association autres cotisations et
droit n'est pas conforme à la
construction de notre pacte social
c'est un mécanisme d'aspiration
assurantiel c'est à dire linverse de
notre système solidaire est plutôt que
de taxer des retraites inférieures à
1300 euros
pourquoi ne pas porter les prélèvements
sociaux sur les revenus du capital au
même niveau que ceux applicables aux
revenus du travail
certes nous avons progressé en la
matière mais pourquoi considéré que le
capital dont on sait qu'ils cassent
l'emploi puisqu'il ne le fait pas
progresser sont moins soumis aux
cotisations que les salaires qui
participent eux à la consommation et
donc à la croissance
et permettez moi de dire à ce stade de
mon propos combien le débat autour de
l'huile de palme et sur la bière a été
je dois dire un petit peu surréaliste
j'imagine un citoyen lambda très
courageux qui auraient suivi nos débats
2h30 sur l'huile de palme et la bière
une demi heure
sur la taxe sur les retraites j'oserais
dire de l'indécence à l'état pur enfin
pour terminer pour raccourcir mon propos
mon collègue dominique watrin l'a dit
lors de son intervention sur l'article
une partie des ressources qui
constituent les recettes prévues dans ce
plfss sont en réalité issues de mesures
adoptés sous le président précédent
gouvernement que nous avions dénoncée
je sais malgré des silences que nous
sommes encore nombreux à les combattre
je pense par exemple aux franchises
médicales qui nuisent à l'accès aux
soins ou encore à la taxe sur les
mutuelles dont nous avons été nombreux à
gauche dans ce plfss à ont demandé la
suppression là encore l'adoption de ces
mesures auraient été un signal positif à
l'égard de celles et ceux de nos
concitoyens qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux à renoncer aux soins pour des
motifs financiers
nous voulions que ce premier plfss soit
celui qui change la donne
nous constatons qu'en l'état actuel des
recettes prévues ne permette au
gouvernement ni de desserrer l'étau que
génère la crise financière ni de
réhausser le niveau de protection
sociale dont ont besoin nos concitoyens
et le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyen et je le dis avec solennité et
fermeté prend toutes ses responsabilités
ce matin et donc par conséquence avec ce
que je viens de dire précédemment nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix que de rejeter
cette troisième partie merci ma chère
collègue la parole est à alain milon
merci monsieur le président madame à
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur général
tout d'abord avant de prendre mon
intervention une petite remarque sur ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure par rapport
aux médecins je voudrais avoir un petit
esprit corporatiste pendant quelques
temps et vous m'en excuserez mais la
quasi-totalité des messages généralistes
n'applique pas de dépassement donne rien
et 90 à 95 % des médecins spécialistes
qui appliquent des dépassements
d'honoraires le font avec tact et mesure
alors avoir les propos que j'ai entendus
dans l'hémicycle pas seul mais madame la
ministre mais les propos que j'ai
entendus dans l'hémicycle condamnant
tous les médecins comme étant des
escrocs est absolument insupportable
pour la plupart des médecins et le
mécontentement que vous entendez
actuellement dans le pays par des
médecins pl via de cette condamnation
que vous leur donnez ils sont tous des
escrocs
non le médecin ne sont pas des escrocs
ils sont là pour soigner la population
il applique là pour la plupart d'entre
les tarifs ou les tarifs opposables où
les tarifs avec tact et mesure et
quelques-uns simplement mérite
évidemment d'être condamné mais
quelques-uns simplement nous estimons
madame la ministre que ce projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
est construit sur une contre vérité
le gouvernement s'appuie en effet sur
des hypothèses de croissance irréalistes
il y a quelques jours la commission
européenne a publié ses prévisions
économiques pour l'ensemble de la zone
euro la commission anticipe comme le fmi
une croissance de seulement 0 4% en 2013
alors que le gouvernement table sur une
croissance de 0 8%
la conséquence d'admission du taux de
croissance pourrait faire déraper le
déficit à 3 5% du pib pour 2014
la commission européenne est également
moins optimiste que le gouvernement
l'activité ne devrait progresser que de
1 2% alors que le gouvernement parie sur
2%
le commissaire aux affaires économiques
et monétaires olli rehn s'attend à ce
que les entreprises limité
si tu leur création d'emplois pour
maintenir leur profitabilité et leur
productivité
alors que le chômage et des hausses
d'impôts devraient peser sur le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages et maintenir la
confiance à un niveau bas fin de
citation
dans ce contexte la courbe du chômage ne
pourra pas s'inverser et je regrette le
projet de loi est donc selon nous fonder
sur une chimère en outre votre projet de
loi se caractérise je vais déjà dit dans
la discussion générale par une avalanche
de taxes
elle touche tous les français et tout
particulièrement le monde de
l'entreprise
toutes ces mesures auront pour
conséquence de ralentir un pan entier de
notre économie et donc d'aggraver la
situation d'emploi je pense en
particulier à l'article 11 qui prévoit
une hausse des taxes de plus d'un
milliard d'euros pour les commerçants
artisans et professions libérales
alors que les entreprises de l'artisanat
et du commerce de proximité crée et
développe des emplois non délocalisables
je pense aussi à l'article 15 qui en
supprimant la déclaration du forfait
pour les emplois à domicile pénalise les
classes moyennes et favorisent le
développement du travail illégal notre
assemblée a supprimé cet article à une
large majorité
mais nous ne faisons pas d'illusions
quant à sa réintroduction par la cnv je
pense aussi à l'article 20 qui prévoyant
une taxation substantielle de la rupture
conventionnelle vide
ce dispositif de sa substance et
pénalise une fois de plus ses salariés
enfin le matraquage des entreprises du
médicament ne peut pas être une
stratégie pérenne et déstabilisera ce
secteur en terme d'emploi et en termes
d'attractivité
par ailleurs nous ne pouvons que
constater votre manque de cohérence les
faits parlent d'eux mêmes le
gouvernement s'est précipité pour
supprimer la tva compétitivité et
promettre de ne pas augmenter la tva
six mois plus tard vous faites
exactement inverse
vous reconnaissez donc implicitement la
nécessité de changements fondamentaux
pour enrayer
perte de compétitivité de nos
entreprises et l'importance de la
corrélation compétitivité coûte
mais en choisissant d'augmenter d'abord
fortement les impôts tant pour les
entreprises que pour les ménages
vous êtes dans l'impossibilité de
financer toutes mesures de réformes
structurelles
celle inverse qu'il aurait fallu faire
en utilisant l'augmentation de la
fiscalité comme mode d'accompagnement la
logique de la tva compétitivité que vous
avez tant décrié était bien inverse
il s'agissait d'amorcer la pompe en
réduisant le coût des charges sociales à
court terme
le temps que les réformes affectant la
compétitivité prennent le relais pour
notre groupe
la seule augmentation des taxes et le
démantèlement des dispositifs déjà mis
en place ne constitue pas une stratégie
pour la sauvegarde notre système de
protection sociale
surtout si elles s'appuient sur des
prévisions de croissance et donc des
recettes irréaliste pour toutes ces
raisons madame le ministre
le groupe ump votre à contre les
recettes du plfss
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur roche
oui monsieur le président à séduire le
matin monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues le vote la
partie recettes du père effet c'est ce
n'est pas anodin c'est un acte
parlementaire dont la dimension
politique est évidente tout autant sans
doute que les le vote de l'article
équilibre du budget alors on peut dire
qu'en ce moment on fait de la politique
mais faisons avec discernement il n'est
pas question de condamner par principe
la totalité des recettes soumis à nos
suffrages
un peu de bonne foi de réalisme personne
dans cet hémicycle n'a de leçon à donner
à quiconque
nous savons bien que dans la situation
actuelle déterminés les recettes de la
protection sociale est une gageure
ce qui se comprend bien puisqu'il s'agit
ni plus ni moins à matcher santé par
exemple que d'élaborer une dame crédible
sans dégrader la qualité de notre
système de soins qui demeure l'un des
meilleurs du monde
autrement dit quel que soit le
gouvernement aux affaires les recettes
sociales sera critiquable critiquer
d'une manière ou d'une autre pour notre
groupe de façon globale on peut
regretter l'augmentation des taxes
salariales
l'absence ou de l'insuffisance de
mesures d'économies qui on le sait va
être un panneau nous est proposé est
insuffisante les taux des taxes et qu
environnemental le champ de nos
discussions était vaste
l'on est tous les points étaient
importants pour pour leurs conséquences
possibles sur le quotidien de nos
concitoyens dans une explication de vote
on ne peut tout évoqué au mais au risque
de paraître réducteur
je voudrais nous voudrions parler de
l'un d'entre eux chacun bien conscience
que ce plfss s'est joué sur un article
emblématique le fameux article 16 qui
crée la casa contribution nouvelle de 0
3% sur les pensions de retraite et
d'invalidité l'examen de cet article a
été l'occasion de reprendre le débat
social clé de la prise en charge la
dépendance et de son financement pour
faire face au risque dépendance sur
gouvernement jospin a mis en place le
pas en 2001 en termes de prise en charge
la dépendance le bila g le bilan de
l'apa est remarquable et je dirais
excellent cela est très important il
faut le rappeler
l'ap a permis un recul de 10 en gros
moyens d'entrer dans l'établissement des
personnes dépendantes
de plus la page joue déjà un rôle
essentiel en matière de restes à charge
des familles puisqu'elle vient en
déduction d'un prise en charge des
personnes un établissement par le
forfait dépendance
le seul problème de forme de ce
dispositif c'est son financement
le financement de l'apa est un serpent
de mer c'est pour y faire face que l'on
a créé la journée de solidarité
la contribution du même nom et la cns 1
mais cela ne suffit plus
les départements sont exsangues alors ce
débat revient nous l'avons eu a vanté
les faits 16 nous l'avons eue pendant le
plfss et nous l'aurons encore le 25
octobre dernier la haute assemblée a
adopté une proposition de loi que je lui
soumettaient avec l'as le soutiennent
mon groupe
udi eu c'est pour régler le problème de
manière pérenne une fois n'est pas
coutume disons le clairement c'est grâce
au groupe r d est ce que ce texte était
adopté
et je les remercie très vivement comme
je remercie très vivement les présidents
de conseils généraux du groupe ump en
particulier rené-paul savary qui ont su
convaincre leurs colères leurs collègues
de l'importance de nos propositions
mais ce texte a été adopté contre l'avis
du gouvernement et malgré l'opposition
du groupe
socialiste c'est exactement le même
scénario qui s'est reproduit avant-hier
avec le vote de notre amendement sur
l'arctique 16 le gouvernement fait
fausse route
parce qu'il est inapproprié de
provisionner deux hommes crédit pour
financer les réformes futures dont on
n'en sait encore rien alors que le
financement des dispositifs existants
n'est plus assurée comment l'apa
va-t-elle survivre à mes collègues amis
socialistes en particulier mes collègues
présidents de conseils généraux je veux
dire ceci depuis trois ans nous
travaillons dans le consensus pour
trouver une solution pérenne à ce
problème au sein de l'adf vous le savez
pertinemment ma ppl et l'amendement que
nous avons adoptée y est à vendre cher
sur l'arctique 16 s'inscrivent dans la
droite file de la politique nous avons
voulu mener ensemble une politique non
pas destinée simplement à défendre et
départements bien sûr que non né à
défendre dispositif excellent social de
l'apa dans ces conditions je vous le dis
là aussi comme je pense et comme je n'ai
ressenti votre comportement m'a déçu et
j'ai mal vécu cet abandon
alors aujourd'hui votre majorité n'est
plus assurée des bruits de couloir
quelques contacts ici ou là les 70 ans
que l'on pourrait espérer de votre part
une volonté de faire vivre
l'amendement de l'article 16 voté par
notre assemblée et pourquoi pas même la
ppl du 25 octobre mais pourquoi ouvrir
les portes la discussion maintenant
alors qu'à deux reprises
vous aviez pu nous manifester votre
soutien par vos votes et ainsi montrer
votre volonté de sauver lapin alors
parce que nous ne voulons pas entrer
dans une posture d'opposition
systématique et stérile celle inverse
que nous vous proposons fait ce qu'il
faut pour sauver la pas et faites le
dans l'immédiat car il ya urgence ne
reporter pas les solutions à 2014 ou
même 2015
car comme l'a confié notre collègue
jacky le menn sur la dépendance beaucoup
beaucoup de choses ont été dites
maintenant il faut agir
alors alors bien sûr pour les échéances
à venir l'opposition pourrait être plus
coopérative
en attendant la grande majorité du
groupe udi us et 30 28 sur 31 32
voteront contre les recettes de ce
préfet cesse pour 2013
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur g km merci monsieur le
président c'est le président malam
ministre voit bien maintenant que le
vote est pratiquement joué n'empêche que
il ya un certain nombre de choses et
remarques à dire j'ai d'abord trois mots
à dire
ce préfet cesse 2013 s'inscrit dans une
dynamique forte c'est la recherche de
l'intérêt général et l'intérêt général
pour tous nos concitoyens
ce préfet cesse ses 1 pén fss la
ministre l'a plusieurs fois rappelé de
protection des français
ce préfet cesse c'est aussi un paint fss
qui s'inscrit dans le redressement des
comptes sociaux sans redressement des
comptes sociaux
nous n'irons pas loin mes chers
collègues nous n'irons pas loin
c'est un père fss aussi de modernisation
du système de santé
je reviens rapidement sur chacun de ces
points sur le problème du redressement
des comptes sociaux
c'est une ardente obligation mes chers
collègues de la minorité actuelle mais
qui furent pendant dix ans la majorité
au niveau national vous nous avez laissé
une situation financière catastrophique
et s'est pas encore c'est jusqu'à il y a
6 mois
je rappel des chiffres 90 milliards de
déficit en cinq ans 20 milliards de
déficit pour l'année 2011 cumulés nous
avons là une situation qui impose à tous
nos concitoyens de comprendre la
situation et nous avançons des solutions
fort pour permettre d'aller de l'avant
en matière de maintien d'un système à
oui on reviendra là dessus c'est pour
aller de l'avant dans la garantie d'un
système social notamment de santé de
qualité et en ce qui concerne ce plfss
quand j'entends dire ici ou là qu'il n'y
a rien qui a été fait 4,4 milliards 600
millions sont mis en plus ce rapport à
l'exercice 2012 pour les hôpitaux 1
milliard 900 millions ce n'est pas rien
pour le secteur médico-social 650
millions dans beaucoup d'ailleurs sont
rattachés aux hôpitaux de structure ce
n'est pas rien avec des mesures qui ont
été prises pour accompagner
l'organisation différentes dans le cadre
des hôpitaux est là bien évidemment il
ne me revient en tête qui a été dit
lorsqu'on a discuté longuement il y a
quelques années en 2009
la loi hôpital patients santé et
territoires on nous promettait on nous
promettait monts et merveilles on a vu
ce que ça a donné
dans le bénéfice est ce qui nous est
présenté heureusement un certain nombre
de propositions dans beaucoup de
propositions que qui ont été reprises
dans le cadre du rapport qui a été
adoptée à l'unanimité de la commission
des affaires sociales qui concerne la
refondation ou leur fondement si on veut
dire du financement des établissements
de santé avec la suppression d'un an de
la convergence tarifaire un peu secteur
public et secteur privé qui était une
catastrophe qui était une catastrophe
des mesures aussi qu'ils vont aller très
rapidement dans le sens d'une
possibilité d'avoir des économie
raisonnée et raisonnable dans la gestion
des hôpitaux et ce n'est pas au
détriment des malades
ce n'est pas au détriment des malades et
moi aussi j'ai un grand respect pour le
corps médical mais j'ai un grand respect
aussi pour nos malades
je crois que nous devons tous et j'en
suis persuadé vous êtes aussi dans le
cadre de cet état d'esprit alors bon
j'entends nos collègues du groupe crc
faire un certain nombre de remarques et
se poser sur une mesure importante
je vais résumer c'est la casa
nous ne partageons partagions pas sur ce
point là une philosophie
nous ne partageons pas autre philosophie
sur ce point là je crois que les
propositions que nous avançons
s'inscrivent pleinement dans notre
volonté mais qui est commune j'en suis
persuadée de prendre en charge nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens les plus
âgées notamment qui sont en
vulnérabilités on a eu effectivement
l'occasion d'en parler lors de la pps
quelques mérites de notre collègue roche
sur la table toutes les conditions
étaient mises toutes les conditions
étaient mises depuis de nombreuses
années ce qu'on nous promettait qu'on
allait résoudre ce problème de la prise
en charge des personnes qui étaient en
dépendance quatre rapports je rappelais
ont été faits tout le monde a été
consulté à rapport au conseil économique
et social des rapports en raison de la
république
des rapports qui ont été faits assemblée
nationale je rappelle qu'au jour celui
de votre collègue député de bord qui
proposait des solutions leur horizon est
combattue certaines notamment celles qui
disaient qu'il faut supprimer le gir 4
75% ont renvoyé je ne sais où
soit vers une finance en particulier des
familles le soin dans le cadre des tests
de retraite mais des solutions à bt
propose il fallait choisir
le gros problème sur lequel tout le
monde se heurtaient c'est celui du
financement les propositions qui sont
faites par le gouvernement aujourd'hui
sont les propositions courageuses et les
revenus ça se débite par wendel de
saucisson les revenus ils doivent est
cherché à appréhender
là où ils sont actuellement dès 2012 dès
là où ils sont chez nos concitoyens des
garanties ont été prises ces garanties
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il y ait des
exonérations ou des gens qui ne sont pas
touchés leur s'ils ne payent pas
d'impôts les autres ses revenus doivent
être touchés
un solidarité et ils le réclament je
suis moi-même retraités et ça ne
ça ne me gênerait pas ça ne me gênerait
pas du tout comprendre sur ma retraite
par contre je serai particulièrement je
serai particulièrement eux peiné de voir
si ç'avait été le cas que les agents de
service hospitalier de mon hôpital
puissent leurs six soirs tête est
pénalisé ils ne sont pas avec cette
mesure compte tenu de leur niveau de
retraite alors squater à ce niveau là
les recettes miracles n'existent pas là
les solutions les solutions sont tout
sur la table
il faut avoir le courage d'aller les
chercher là où elles sont et de les
présenter dans le cadre le père et c'est
ce que fait le gouvernement
c'est ce que fait le ministre alors bon
je serai pas pu lancer tu passes ton
temps de parole j'ai été très calme
pendant ces trois jours et j'ai tout
entendu et compris le cadre de ces
amendements ou effectivement là vous
avez raison pendant plus d'une heure et
demie
on a confondu santé publique ou chercher
à nous vaste et sous les thermes santé
publique des problèmes qui sont que son
petit pré carré et on essayait conformes
ou faire semblant confondre défense de
l'emploi et santé publique
alors là mes chers collègues aussi la
majorité je me rappelle avoir retiré je
me ratais de l'ex majorité
je me rappelle avoir retiré au ça vous
fait rire car entendement
lorsque madame la ministre de l'époque
nous avait dit nous avait dit il y aura
une grande loi de santé publique
nous lui avons fait confiance j'ai
moi-même retirer 40 amendements blogo en
lisant un ministre on vous fait crédit
là dessus on attend on discutera de ses
points et puis ça ressort bien sûr
jamais eu de l'oise santé publique
pas plus qu'il n'y a eu de prise en
charge à fond de la dépendance
on attend toujours et bien ce courage et
là il est au niveau de notre
gouvernement qui aujourd'hui va sortir
une loi santé publique et on aura
l'occasion de parler de ce qu'on a
esquissé
chacun a son territoire le regardant pas
l'intérêt général qui défendons ici un
exploitant ceux ci qui défend dans la à
noter exploitants alors je veux dire que
les leçons on n'en veut pas on a un
budget paix les faits c'est ce qui a un
budget au service des français et nous
sommes fiers de voter pour ce budget
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur jean marie vanlerenberghe le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je serais assez bref puisque
mon collègue gérard roche a vous a déjà
donné notre explication de vote
je ne reviendrai pas madame la ministre
longuement sur ce que j'ai dit mais qui
est essentiel dans l'adx dans la
discussion générale sur ce plfss
ce plfss manque d'un cap essentiel c'est
à dire le calendrier sur le retour à
l'équilibré des comptes de la sécurité
sociale
nous sommes dans un projet de loi de
finances et c'est un projet on le voit
bien déséquilibré que vous nous avez
présenté et qui ne peut nous convenir
vous en conviendrez en l'état et
pourtant nous ne faisons aucun procès
d'intention au contraire j'avais bien
entendu comme vous tous le président de
la république dans sa fameuse anaphore
lors du débat présidentiel qui nous
avait annoncé un changement d'attitude
un changement de méthode je passe sur
les les cases propositions plus
j'attendais qu'il en soit ainsi
dans les relations entre le gouvernement
et le parlement
eh bien vous constatez que aujourd'hui
nous avons les mêmes défauts qui hier le
ministre arrive bardé de certitudes
convaincu qu'il a raison surtout avec
aucune marge de manoeuvre financière
comment voulez vous que le parlement
existe dans ces circonstances le
parlement profite alors de quelques
opportunités pour voter des amendements
qui on le sait s'ils proviennent de
l'opposition seront vite validé par la
cmp sur la pression bien sûr de sa
majorité et où sur pression de sa
majorité parlementaire pardon ou quand
ils ne sont pas tout simplement refusé
avant par le gouvernement
il en fut il en sera ainsi des
propositions entre autres je vais pas
rappeler toutes les tous les amendements
que nous avons déposés sur les auto
entrepreneurs la rupture conventionnelle
sur le forfait des particuliers
employeurs et sur ce que vient de
rappeler notre ami gérard roche sur
l'emblème ap
l'emblématique kazan alors sur toutes
ces propositions
ce fut de votre part non non et non
eh bien vous ne vous étonnerez pas qu
évidemment nouveau tognon nouveau ton
pardon non à votre plfss
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
madame aline archimbaud nous voulons
d'abord remercier tous ceux qui ont
permis que ce débat se tienne et tous
ceux qui ont participé à un débat riche
et nous voulons remercier nous voulons
remercier monsieur le rapporteur général
pour le travail important vous avez
fourni et la démarche constructive que
vous avez impulsé malgré toutes les
difficultés
le groupe écologiste votera pour la
partie recettes du plfss 2013
tout d'abord parce que comme nous
l'avons dit dès la discussion générale
nous soutenons
globalement le père fss 2013 qui certes
est un projet de transition mais qui
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
ne propose aucune remise en cause des
prestations servies par le régime
d'assurance maladie obligatoire
certaines mesures attendues depuis
longtemps sont dans ce plfss et
notamment la fin de la convergence
tarifaire public privé et là je rejoins
mon collègue
le maine cette convergence tarifaire
public privé était en train d'asphyxier
complètement l'hôpital public la fin de
cette convergence devrait permettre
d'envisager de lui redonner à l'hôpital
public la possibilité d'assurer ses
missions de service public
si précieuse formation recherche
accueille 24 heures sur 24
accueil de tous y compris les personnes
modestes et en grande précarité
tout cela a un coût qui doit être
reconnu et assumé par notre pays
le remboursement des vga 100% est aussi
parmi d'autres une mesure très attendue
que nous saluons et qui évitera bien des
drames
concernant les recettes qui doivent
permettre la mise en place de ces
mesures
nous nous félicitons qu'elle s'appuie
sur des dispositions allant dans le sens
de la justice sociale et de la
diminution des inégalités sociales qui
ont explosé ces dernières années
et de ce point de vue nous nous
félicitons que le sénat ait rétabli
l'article 14
enfin nous estimons que plusieurs
positions adoptées hier manifeste la
volonté que notre pays s'engage aussi
dans une politique de santé
environnementale
le sénat s'est en effet prononcé pour
des mesures permettant aux chefs
d'entreprise qu'ils souhaitent de
faciliter les déplacements de leurs
salariés à vélo il a proposé également
la taxation de deux produits dont
l'utilisation massive et dangereuse
l'huile de palme et l'aspartame
ces mesures mérite autre chose que des
remarques humoristique elle dans la
tente d'un plan général de santé
annoncée est prévue en 2013 ses
positions du sénat ces propositions
certes ponctuelles donne un signal est
manifeste aussi la volonté d'aller dans
le sens d'un développement significatif
de la prévention dans les politiques de
santé publique
cette politique répondant évidemment et
cela a été souligné d'abord à d'immenses
enjeux sanitaires mais elles répondent
aussi puisque nous sommes dans un projet
de loi de finances elles répondent
aussi à l'impérative nécessité de
rétablir les comptes sociaux
je vous remercie merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à monsieur jean pierre
caffet
merci monsieur le le président à l'issue
de notre débat sur cette troisième
partie et pressentant que la discussion
pourrait s'interrompre
j'ai envie de dire quelques mots sur ce
plfss
malgré ses imperfections car qui
pourrait prétendre de présenter devant
le parlement un projet de loi parfait
malgré ses imperfections
je considère avec mon groupe que ce
plfss est courageuse et que comme l'a
dit jacky le menn
il répondait à l'intérêt général car mes
chers collègues que vous le vouliez ou
non il faut bien partir du constat que
notre protection sociale est malade elle
est malade de ses déficits
elle est malade de sa dette accumulée je
ne veux pas revenir sur les propos que
j'ai tenus il ya quelques jours les les
dix années qui se sont écoulées ont vu
notre protection sociale accumulée 160
milliards de dettes sous les
gouvernements de droite 160 milliards
dont 130 transférés à la cades est c'est
à dire une charge sur les générations
futures et dans ces conditions
mes chers collègues il n'est pas
extravagant que le gouvernement
s'attaque à ses déficits
il n'est pas absurde il n'est pas
surréaliste que ce gouvernement essaye
de tenir les comptes et inscrivent notre
protection sociale dans l'impératif car
nous pensons qu'il s'agit d'un impératif
de rétablissement des comptes de notre
pays
je prends des comptes publics bien
entendu car voyez vous si nous ne
maîtrisons pas ses déficits
et c'est une tentation d'une certaine
partie de la droite
si nous nous maîtrisons pas ses déficits
de la protection sociale
à ce moment là le système pourra exposer
et les tenants de la privatisation d'une
partie ou de pans entiers de la
protection sociale pourront enfin
triomphé et c'est ça le danger qui nous
menace
mes chers collègues et personnellement
je me refuserai toujours à ce que des
ports entier y compris de l'assurance
maladie soit privatisée parce que nous
ne serions pas arrivés à tenir les
comptes de la protection sociale et pour
tenir les comptes de la protection
sociale
ce gouvernement a proposé des économies
et des recettes et le paradoxe mes chers
collègues c'est que à l'issue de ce
débat nous sortons avec eux je n'ai pas
tenu les compteurs exactement et je
pense que le gouvernement pourrait seule
répondre à cette question nous sortons
avec pratiquement 800 ou 900 millions de
recettes en moins
tel a été le déluge hier soir de
nouvelles taxes ce qui fait que on ne
sait pas on peut en tout cas
personnellement je ne sais pas at-elle
nouveau à quel niveau nous nous étions
800 millions ou 900 millions de recettes
en moins ça n'est pas possible de
continuer comme ça il faut dire quand
même que la droite porte une
responsabilité dans le refus
systématique peut vous avez eu que vous
avez montré tout au cours de ce débat
pour équilibrer ses comptes
la meilleure preuve c'est que vous avez
refusé l'article 11 alors que le régime
des indépendants est en déficit
chronique alors qu'il est menacé alors
qu'on ne sait pas comment seront payés
les prestations dans un an ou deux
ou peut-être même l'année prochaine en
2013 vous avez refusé de calibrer ce
compte
alors que le conseil d'administration du
régime social des indépendants avaient
accepté ces mesures est pourquoi les
avait-elle accepté parce que ces mesures
étaient justes tu as paulette de
l'opposition parce qu'elle mettait fin à
une injustice absolument invraisemblable
c'est à dire le déplafonnement des
cotisations maladie au delà de revenus
de 180000 euros par an et que
non content de ça le gouvernement avait
diminué la cotisation sur les revenus
les moins importants ce qui faisait que
450 mille ressortissants de ce régime
béret - alors même que le régime est
équilibré alors vous pouvez nous
raconter à longueur de séances à longues
heures d'intervention quand nous ne
ferons pas suffisamment pour équilibrer
les comptes
mais toute votre comportement pendant
cette séance pendant ce débat a été de
faire en sorte que la sécurité sociale
ne soit pas équilibré faut-il continuer
les déficits à ce point quant aux
économies
mes chers collègues enfin s au fait dans
la justice
est ce qu'il y a dans ce projet de loi
présenté par le gouvernement
une quelconque atteinte aux droits et à
la protection des assurés sociaux
y à t'il comme les années précédentes
des déremboursements
y at il des franchises médicales non
j'ai entendu parler des dépenses il
fallait plus sur l'ondam il fallait plus
sur lot de l'ondam l'ondam a été fixée à
2,7 pour cent
c'est une progression par rapport à
l'année précédente
ça fait 350 millions de plus dont 150
seront consacrés à des investissements
hospitaliers
faut-il à ce point refusée
l' équilibre des comptes dans la justice
pour que nous intervenions notre séance
aujourd'hui et que nous et que nous ne
puissions pas discuter des dépenses je
crois que ça n'est pas une attitude
responsable en tout cas tel est mon
sentiment
quant à l'avenir nous aurons bien
évidemment des discussions sur le
financement de la protection sociale
je partage complètement ce qu'a dit mon
collègue jacky le menn oui nous avons un
désaccord il faudra bien savoir comment
sera financé la protection sociale et
quels seront les réformes en ce sens ce
que je voulais vous dire simplement
chers collègues c'est que aujourd'hui
les ressources de la protection sociale
porte
à 80% sur des revenus d'activité 80% ce
sont les actifs qui y participent et que
les revenus des remplacements au bout de
dix ans où ils n'ont pas augmenté
participe à 5 % du financement de la
protection sociale
était-il donc extravagant de prendre
cette mesure soit la casa est de faire
en sorte que sur un nouveau risque dont
il va bien falloir trouver les sources
de financement on fasse contribuer un
certain nombre de retraités d'ailleurs
pas les pas les plus pauvres pas les
plus désavantagés puisque seuls
participeront à cette à ce financement
ceux qui sont assujettis au taux de csg
de 6 6%
et très franchement chers collègues
ce sont eux qui sont menacés par ce
risque en grande partie donc ces débats
sont devant nous je regrette que nous ne
puissions pas les mener en abordant la
quatrième partie et notamment les
dépenses car très franchement nous
aurions beaucoup à dire nous aussi
je terminerai puisque j'ai dépassé mon
temps de parole en rendant hommage à
notre rapporteur général dont la
compétence la constance a été manifeste
au cours de ce débat et mes derniers
mots seront pour vous dire que nous
aussi nous avons nos responsabilités
merci mon cher collègue la parole est à
monsieur robert tropéano merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre mes
chers collègues dans un contexte de
crise particulièrement difficile ce
plfss amorcer le redressement des
comptes sociaux
nous devons nous appuyer cité il marque
une véritable rupture avec le
gouvernement précédent qui par une
politique irresponsable
a très largement contribué à augmenter
les déficits c'est ainsi que notre
système de protection sociale était
menacé
notre collègue jean pierre plancade l'a
exprimé en discussion générale
nous sommes favorables à l'économie
générale de ce texte
au terme de l'examen de cette troisième
partie relative aux recettes pour 2013
nous nous réjouissons que 5 des
amendements présentés par notre groupe
est connu un sort favorable
nous avons permis d'exclure les
contributions des employeurs aux régimes
de prévoyance complémentaire de leurs
salariés du champ d'application de la
taxe sur les salaires qui je le rappelle
apporte aux salariés à leur famille une
certaine sécurité lors de la survenance
d'un événement grave
nous avons également supprimé l'article
15 qui était véritablement une fausse
bonne idée
nous avons tous conscience qu'il est
nécessaire de renforcer les droits
sociaux de ses salariés mais votre
mesure madame la ministre aurait eu
l'effet inverse
s'agissant de la taxe sur la bière nous
nous félicitons des débats que nous
avons eus dans cette enceinte hier au
soir et du compromis auquel nous avons
abouti
l'intérêt des petits brasseurs
s'agissant des boissons énergisantes
nous avons envoyé un signe fort à la
jeunesse notre pays et contribuer à
conforter la politique de santé publique
menée par le gouvernement
vous l'aurez compris notre groupe le rds
eux dans sa très grande majorité votera
donne en faveur de cette troisième
partie du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2013 merci
mon cher collègue madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président les
explications de vote ont eu lieu le vote
semble se dessiner au fond il flotte
comme un parfum de fin de débat à ce
moment et je voudrais
donc tout en espérant que ce ne soit pas
le cas je voudrais donc remercier bien
sûr monsieur le rapporteur général pour
le travail remarquable qu'il a effectués
et l'engagement qui a été le sien non
seulement pour porter le texte
ce projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale dans votre hémicycle mais aussi
pour faire en sorte de l'améliorer et de
le rendre plus constructif encore je
voudrais dire que j'espère qu'au terme
probable de ces débats nos concitoyens
sortiront mieux éclairer des choix des
uns et des autres pour l'avenir de notre
protection sociale
vous me permettrez d'en douter mais au
fond c'est le souhait que l'on peut
avoir que se dessinent des projets pour
l'avenir de la sécurité sociale dans
notre pays
sécurité sociale à laquelle nos
concitoyens sont éminemment attachés et
nous pouvons espérer que apparaissent au
fond des lignes directrices au terme de
discussions qui parfois peuvent avoir
donné le sentiment d'être d'avoir été
empreinte d'une certaine complexité
voire d'une certaine confusion mais si
les français s'y retrouve jean serait la
première satisfait parce qu'au fond que
restera-t-il des amendements qui auront
été ici présentée puisque nous n'allons
pas aller de l'avant sans doute dans le
débat sur les dépenses que nous devons
engager et je serai moi même d'ailleurs
bien en peine d'expliquer à l'opinion ce
que des taxes qui ont été voter des
amendements qui ont été portés il
restera au bout du compte je voudrais
indiquer au delà que pour le
gouvernement il est absolument décisif
d'inscrire ce projet de loi dans la
perspective d'une trajectoire de
rétablissement de l'équilibré des
comptes publics
parce que les comptes sociaux
contribuent à l'équilibré ou au
déséquilibre
comptes publics est donc le gouvernement
assume clairement et fermement sa
volonté au terme de la législature au
terme de la mandature d'avoir rétabli
l'équilibré des comptes de la sécurité
sociale comme cela a été dit par
jean-pierre café le nom rétablissement
des comptes aboutir est purement et
simplement à une fuite en avant et à
l'ouverture à des perspectives
alternatives pour le financement de
notre protection sociale c'est-à-dire
des financements privés auxquels nous ne
pouvons pas nous résoudre et je veux le
dire de ce point de vue là l'affirmation
d'une exigence de responsabilité
financière ne peut pas apparaître comme
la continuité de la politique menée au
cours des dernières années puisque nous
nous retrouvons au contraire à devoir
prendre des mesures pour faire ce qui
n'a pas été fait et garantir les
équilibres de la sécurité sociale
contrairement à ce qui a été indiqué je
veux dire à monsieur milon que les
hypothèses financières sur lesquelles se
fondent notre texte sont des hypothèses
crédibles sincère et d'ailleurs
l'ensemble de la politique
gouvernementale en dehors de ce projet
de loi vise précisément à garantir ou à
permettre que la croissance soit au
rendez-vous et que les hypothèses de
croissance soit au rendez vous et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
clairement fortement annoncé notre
engagement dans un pacte de
compétitivité dont nous voulons que le
résultat soit précisément qu'il permette
de relancer la croissance dans notre
dans notre pays je veux dire que cette
volonté de rétablissement de l'équilibré
des comptes ne se fait pas uniquement
sur la base de recherche d'économies
financières même si ces économies figure
dans ce texte mais se fait également par
la volonté de mettre en place des
réformes structurelles réformes
structurelles dont nous n'aurons pour
l'essentiel sans doute pas l'occasion de
débattre puisque elles sont inscrites
dans les articles à venir la partie 4 de
ce texte de loi réforme structurelle qui
vise à consolider de façon durable les
régimes de retraite par étapes à
répartition réformes structurelles qui
vise à consolider l'hôpital public tout
en permettant que son financement soit
mieux assurer réformes structurelles en
faveur d'une médecine de proximité qui
permettent de concentrer l'hôpital
public sur ses tâches centrales qui
permettent de d'éviter que l'hôpital
public ne soit la porte d'entrée
systématique dans notre système de santé
et re renforcement réhabilitation d'une
médecine de proximité qui jusqu'à
maintenant a été laissé de côté et puis
de réformes structurelles aussi par la
volonté d'étendre les droits sociaux de
nos concitoyens ce dont nous ne
discuterons pas extension des droits des
retraités extension des droits des
femmes à travers des mesures fortes pour
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
ou la contraception
l'extension des droits encore à travers
la perspective de mise en place d'une
réforme
enfin ambitieuse de l'accompagnement de
la perte d'autonomie
encore faudrait-il que nous puissions
aborder ces débats et je voudrais dire
que moi je suis prête à entendre
beaucoup d'argumentation sur ceux qui ne
figureraient pas dans ce texte mais je
ne suis pas prête à laisser dire à
certain nombre de choses qui ne
correspondent pas à la réalité des
dispositions que nous présentons il est
difficile d'entendre que dans ce texte
nous n'aurions pas procéder à une mise à
contribution des revenus du capital plus
significative que ce qui était
auparavant
cela nous est reproché sur certains
bancs mais ne faisons pas comme si
depuis l'arrivée aux responsabilités de
ce gouvernement il n'y avait pas eu la
volonté claire résolu de mettre à
contribution les revenus du capital
précisément pour que les revenus du
travail ne soient pas les seuls à
financer la sécurité sociale et donc je
veux bien entendre que certains ne
souhaitent pas soutenir ce projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
et pas à ce motif la de la même façon il
me paraît difficile d'expliquer que tout
d'un coup cette année
nous voudrions nous ne pourrions pas où
certains ne pourraient pas voter ce
texte parce que il y aurait des
financement de la sécurité sociale qui
serait assise sur l'impôt et non pas sur
les cotisations ça existe depuis
toujours et ça n'est pas une nouveauté
il y a dans notre système de sécurité
sociale pour l'ensemble des branches de
la sécurité sociale
une partie du financement qui est assis
sur des cotisations solidaire et une
partie qui repose sur la fiscalité au
nom de la solidarité la cmu par exemple
en matière d'assurance maladie la
prévention avec des mesures de santé
publique et de protection
j'ai entendu ici ou là au cours des
derniers jours la volonté d'ailleurs
d'accroître la partie de la fiscalité à
travers la mise en place de taxations
nouvelles auxquelles d'ailleurs le
gouvernement n'était pas favorable mais
dont on ne peut pas considérer qu'il y
ait une remise en cause dans ce texte là
je le dis de l' équilibre d'ensemble
entre mesures fiscales et cotisations et
je crois d'ailleurs que nous aurons dans
les mois à venir c'est le rôle qui a été
confiée au conseil pour le financement
de la protection sociale nous aurons à
déterminer la part précisément qui doit
revenir dans le financement de la
protection sociale à l'impôt et aux
cotisations sociales mais de façon
globale ce texte tel qu'il vous est
présenté ne modifie pas l'équilibré
général entre recours à la fiscalité et
recours à la cotisation
donc c'est un argument qui pour ne pas
voter ce texte ne peut pas prospérer de
façon satisfaisante de la même façon je
veux dire quand même très clairement que
l'eau peut être opposée et je l'entends
on peut être opposé à la mise en place
d'une cotisation sur exceptionnelle sur
les revenus des retraités
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire pourquoi
je pensais avec le gouvernement que
cette contribution était une
contribution
juste équilibré dans la mesure où elles
exonérait les retraites non imposables
dans la mesure où elle permettait d'
engager une réforme de l'accompagnement
de la perte d'autonomie mais je ne
rentre pas d'amendé et et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire aussi que ça me
paraissait être un ferment de solidarité
intergénérationnelle dans le financement
de la sécurité sociale
mais je ne reprends pas ce débat mais
qu'on ne dise pas que nous allons
calibrer la réforme de la perte
d'autonomie sur le montant des
ressources aujourd'hui appelée à aucun
moment le gouvernement n'a dit cela à
aucun moment le gouvernement n'a indiqué
que c'était les ressources aujourd'hui
prélevé ou en 2013 qui serait prélevée
qui formeraient le cadre financier de la
réforme à venir nous avons dit que
c'était une contribution et qui appelait
qui appelait une réforme à venir
laquelle devrait comporter un facteur
financier pérenne
donc évidemment la réforme de la
dépendance entre guillemets ou de la
perte d'autonomie n'est pas aujourd'hui
définis en termes financiers par ce
texte de loin la seule chose que ce
texte de loi définisse c'est la volonté
d'aller vers une réforme de la perte
d'autonomie et d'une réforme qui soit
solidaire qui repose sur un financement
solidaire et pas sur un financement des
privés et un reste à charge
supplémentaire pour vos concitoyens donc
là encore un argument qui ne peut pas
être mis en avant pour ne pas voter ce
texte quant au reste à charge de nos
concitoyens c'est une des priorité pour
ce gouvernement
et j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises nous avons engagé la
politique de réduction du reste à charge
à travers la mise en place d'un accord
ou le l'encouragement d'un accord sur
les dépassements d'honoraires nous
savons bien qu'il faut aller au delà il
nous l'avons dit la politique qui a été
menée au cours des dernières années
n'est pas une politique satisfaisante
simplement nous avons à reprendre
l'ensemble est aujourd'hui nous ne
sommes pas en mesure
compte tenu de l'état des finances
publiques de procéder
sur tous les terrains à la fois de
supprimer les franchises qui ont été
mises en place de supprimer les restes à
charges qui augmentent et dont on sait
que pour une grande part pour ce qui est
des soins courants ils relèvent des
dépassements d'honoraires puisque les
soins courants ne sont plus remboursés
qu'à 50 ou 55 % du fait des dépassements
d'honoraires et donc nous avons la
volonté d'engager cette politique
globale il faudra du temps il faudra de
l'énergie il faut aussi que le
rétablissement des comptes soit au
rendez vous sinon ne pourront pas aller
bien loin là je voudrais remercier les
orateurs du groupe socialiste du groupe
écologiste du groupe r d est ce qu'ils
ont apporté leur soutien à ce texte à sa
philosophie à sa volonté de
responsabilité à sa volonté de justice
parce que on ne dira jamais assez que
c'est un texte qui est un texte qui
étend les droits de nos concitoyens que
c'est un texte de justice et de
protection et que c'est cette justice et
cette protection à laquelle il sera fait
obstacle en ne votant pas la partie
recettes de ce plfss
chacun assume ses responsabilités le
gouvernement assume les siennes sa
responsabilité c'est de garantir la
protection de nos concitoyens de
garantir l'avenir de la protection
sociale de garantir une politique de
justice et c'est en ce sens que nous
travaillons c'est en ce sens que nous
continuerons à travailler et notre
fermeté est inébranlable
merci madame la ministre je mets donc
aux voix la troisième partie du projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2013 et en application de
l'article 59 de règlement le scrutin
public est de droit il va être procédé
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement ceux qui souhaitent
voter pour la troisième partie
remettront aux secrétaires un bulletin
blanc
ceux qui le souhaitent voter contre la
troisième partie un bulletin bleu et
ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir
remettront un bulletin rouge le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
le scrutin est ouvert
shi
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos et j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
on
comme la ministre mes chers collègues je
vous donne lecture résultats du scrutin
numéro 33 sur la troisième partie du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2013 nombre de
votants 345 nombre de suffrages exprimés
341 majorité des absolue des suffrages
exprimés 171 pour l'adoption 155 contre
186 en conséquence donc la troisième
partie du plfss n'est pas adopté mes
chers collègues la troisième partie du
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale pour 2013 ayant été mes chers
collègues je vous demandais de rester
parce qu'il ya un deuxième vote sur
l'ensemble du projet donc la troisième
partie donc de ce plfss pour 2013 a été
rejetée la quatrième partie de ce projet
de loi est considérée donc comme rejetée
en conséquence je vais mettre aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2013 est ce qu'il y a des explications
de vote
il n'y en a pas je mets donc aux voix
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2013 et en application de l'article 59
du règlement le scrutin public est de
droit donc il va être procédé dans les
conditions fixées par l'article 56 du
règlement
le scrutin est ouvert
nos demandes a voté le scrutin est clos
et j'invite madame mesdames et messieurs
les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
résultats donc du scrutin numéro 34 sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2013 nombre de votants 346 nombre de
suffrages exprimés 342 majorité absolue
des suffrages exprimés 172 pour
l'adoption 156 contre 186 en conséquence
l'ensemble du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2013 est rejeté nous quittons
l'hémicycle du sénat nous reviendrons
bien entendu dans nos différentes
tranches d'information de 19h et de 22h
sur les conséquences du vote du sénat ce
matin mais il il y aura avant cela un
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
parlementaire à 15 heures avec les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
présenté aujourd'hui par perrine
tarneaud très bonne journée à tous